[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I have the privilege of
speaking with psychologists best-selling
author and most renowned intellectual in
the world today Dr Jordan Peterson
Dr Peterson thank you so much my
pleasure well uh I can add to the list
of your
many uh sins sins uh stand up comedian
last night at comedy Unleashed in
Hackney at the backyard Comedy Club you
did your was it your first comedy set
um
yes uh my first comedy set as
perpetrator rather than victim
yeah yeah and did you enjoy it it was
fun yeah I read this little kids book I
wrote uh called this is not a hat I read
it for wrote it for my two-year-old
grandson and uh it was a Dr Seuss like
poem and people I had read it at a
dinner meeting weirdly enough a while
back and people were there encouraged me
to
read it as part of this comedy said it's
I thought well I described it as white
man's rap for two-year-olds which is
basically what it was so yeah it was
really fun and the comedy set was great
unbelievably funny it was such a relief
to go to a comedy venue that was funny
Remember When
comedians used to be funny some of them
still are
Bill Burr's special on Netflix the new
special is pretty good yeah yeah but you
said last night that you're going to
release two children's books is that is
that is that poem going to be wonderful
well I have it's complicated because I'm
releasing a book in October called an
ABC of childhood tragedy and it's
for children but it's not it's really
really dark and Gothic but it's also
it's it's
it consists of these poems I wrote about
how adults
mystery children
and there I wrote it when I was doing a
lot of clinical work and so was
disturbed about what I was seeing but
they're also blackly comedic and so you
there each of them is a four stanza poem
about
a particular Pathway to Devastation for
children but there are they also have a
humorous
twist in them and then I had them
illustrated by Yulia fogra who did my
illustrations for my last book beyond
order who's a really gifted illustrator
and she made these unbelievably
beautiful and deep illustrations and so
it's this strange intermingling of the
gothic the humerus and the Beautiful all
all arrayed together and that's a with
strange Nexus a darkness and humor and
beauty and so the books sort of occupy
that Niche there's two of them we'll
release one at a time and we did a lot
of
well there's other uh elements to the
creative production but that'll all be
released starting at the end of October
I don't know what people think because
the poems are very very dark and so
they're definitely not for children but
I've also written some books that are
genuinely for children especially for
very young children and some of them
were derived from poems verses that I
wrote for my own kids when they were
little when I would play with them and
then I found a while back that I had a
talent I suppose for writing verse I
wrote it I wrote a screenplay called The
Water of Life which is a an adaptation
of Grimm's brother fairy tale and that's
been really fun I've been recording some
music for it we have three of the songs
because as I said it's a musical we have
three of the songs recorded in draft
form already and I've been working with
a bunch of musicians which I just love
so fun
and I I can hardly think of anything I
would rather do than that so it was
really fun there's an interest there in
in children's stories then yeah what
what where does that interest for you
come from why have you focused on a
screenplay and two books and this this
poetry is clearly so well you never know
if you're if you're pursuing something
creative you actually don't know why not
really because the creative Pursuit is
the discovery of why in some if you can
say exactly why you're doing an artistic
project you're probably producing
propaganda most of the time if you're
doing something creative you discover
why long after and if it's a work of
creative genius it might take
generations of people hundreds of years
to discover why you were doing it
because art really is on the Forefront
of cognitive transformation I mean
literally and practically
art especially imaginative art but any
true art
it's it's not philosophy yet right but
it's also not the unknown it's right on
the border and or that's where artists
live the Open People by temperament they
live on the border between border and
chaos and they're farther out into the
chaos which is why they often have
chaotic lives and often can't catalyze
an identity right because they're also
one of the problems with being creative
and we're seeing that a lot of the
people who have identity issues let's
say in the modern world
they may have their psychological
problems and and that's generally uh
highly likely but they also tend to be
more creative and the downside of
creativity is that it's very difficult
to catalyze identity because you're
mutable if you're creative because
you're not
by definition if you're creative you're
not the same thing from moment to moment
and you see this in this insistence
about the mutability of identity well
you know you can be one gender one
minute and another the next it's like
well yes in some sense but what do you
what the hell do you expect the people
around you to do right to keep up with
your mutable Transformations like good
luck that's actually interesting there's
if there's a correlation then between
creatives and people who hold this
Progressive oh definitely it's a huge
predictor well openness which is the
creativity Dimension is the best
predictor of liberal political belief
what what are the best predictors from a
psychological point of view why well it
strikes me that the film and music are
very pro-establishment at the moment and
Hyper Progressive accommodating seems to
be not so much but for a psychological
point of view what why is that is it is
is it simply that the personality traits
line up or is it possible that there's a
that these groups of people communities
can ossify in their in their thinking
well the the the
it's it's very complicated
I would say that the political
proclivity of the artistic temperament
at the moment is manifesting itself in a
way that runs counter to the essence of
the artistic temperament and so if
you're on the artistic side let's say
you might be more willing to speak for
what hasn't been included and what's
diverse
right but when you make that into a
mantra and then you impose that
requirement on your own art well
then you're sawing off the branch that
you sit on because the one thing that
artists have
it's the only thing they have is
creative freedom and that's a very
expensive thing to have because the
probability that you're going to be
successful
as a creative artist is virtually zero
now if you are successful you can be
hyper successful but
it's a high stakes
it's a high risk High return game it
probably won't work but if it does work
it works better than anything else but
it'll only work if
you can't put a priori
demands on the manifestation of the
creative spirit
not not in some arbitrary political
sense you can't subordinate
look you can't subordinate what's
highest to what's what's lower you
cannot subordinate the Divine to the
political not without getting yourself
not without getting yourself in a lot of
trouble and if you have a Divine spark
let's say that's a creative spark and
you subordinate it to the political
first of all there is no bigger sin than
you could that you could commit it's a
it's really a bad idea it's a bad idea
psychologically because the thing about
creative people I had lots of them as
clients lots of my clients weren't
creative by the way but lots of them
were and I had to treat them quite
differently
uh creative people cannot live without
being creative that's the Wellspring of
their psychic energy so to speak
psychological energy I don't mean you
know
uh necromancy and and divination psychic
and so it's just like an extroverted
person Withers unless they can be around
other people you know and an agreeable
person Withers unless they have someone
to take care of and a conscientious
person Withers unless they have some
duty to to uphold a creative person
Withers unless they're doing something
creative and if they subordinate that to
the merely political then they
they're they're tearing out their own
heart and certainly that's happening on
the and then there's there's without
realizing they're doing it so take for
example uh the film director Olivia
Wilde calling you a pseudo-intellectual
and and Villa using you as the model
itself yeah that's a funny king a king
of the years that's a very strange sort
of cake but it it it's the epitome of of
a lack of uh intellectual curiosity and
you'd think that that the people in the
creative industry would want to explore
things instead of I don't think she even
realized it's probably that she's being
political there she she it's second
nature to her almost as well yeah
required well that well that's the
darker side of this so I you know I
outlined the positive side in some sense
but the darker side is
if you're
there isn't anything that's more
there isn't anything higher than genuine
creative endeavor
and it should be properly put on a
pedestal and generally is in some sense
but
it it opens up a domain of Temptation
and the Temptation is to let your
political belief so just your belief in
this in in some sense it's not even
yours because almost
all people have political beliefs that
many other people share and so they're
not their beliefs so Carl Jung the
psychoanalyst said people don't have
ideas
ideas have people
and that's right and so you think those
ideas are yours it's like no they're not
that's 20 million people 200 million
people
have the same ideas how are they yours
you did you create these ideas highly
unlikely you very rarely meet someone
who comes up with a novel political idea
especially on any ideological front and
so
it's easy to adopt an ideology and it's
very satisfying because it explains
everything without any effort and then
it's even then there's another
Temptation which is well I'll take my
etiology and I will
put it in the a position that
superordinates the artist I mean what a
deal that is and so then you can show
how you're morally Superior to
Shakespeare it's like really you're
morally Superior to Shakespeare are you
that's your claim well you know he's a
dead white man he's like oh I see so
you've got you've got that all over them
do you and that's your that's actually
what you're claiming you're actually
claiming that what you believe makes you
morally Superior to Shakespeare
and that doesn't have a little whiff of
narcissism about it so you know you go
into art galleries now
it's very hard for me to go into art
galleries often now because you'll see
something that's so spectacularly great
that you could look at it for like a
year and and in some sense people do
right because they worship these pieces
of art they celebrate them and then
you'll see some the comment by an art
critic and they'll talk about the moral
failings of the artist
regardless of their time and place and
it's it's basically what it is is the
art critic is trumpeting themselves as
morally Superior to whoever made this
amazing thing that's worth like a
billion dollars and not only that but
offering the viewer the temptation to do
the same it's like oh this is great I
could never do that I'm quite
minimal in relationship to this
remarkable Talent
oh but I have the correct political
opinions thus I'm a better person it's
like oh my God that's so it's so
narcissistic it's so toxic and it's the
death of art it's the death of art like
the art like this we just won't last a
generation
well you know and that's the other thing
in the artistic world is that
the artistic world is always cluttered
up by propagandistic ideology and what
time does is winnow that all out and so
I like going to Modern Art Museums I
would probably generally
prefer a modern art museum to a classic
art museum although I like both because
I sometimes you see some Modern Art is
so good that it's just beyond belief but
most of it's just junk but that's okay
because the junk gets winnowed out you
know and but it's the same I think it
was Robert Heinlein the I think it was
Heinlein who said that 95 of everything
is [ __ ] and and that's not
pessimistic you know there is this
replication crisis so-called in the
social sciences that that's been
trumpeted much in the last 10 years and
people have been falling all over
themselves to make science much worse in
an attempt to cure the replication
crisis well it meant that a lot of the
classic studies that were done in
disciplines particularly like social
psychology but many social sciences
disciplines didn't replicate didn't
repeat when other people tried to repeat
them so they were published in high
status journals and they got a lot of
press and attention short term like over
maybe a 10-year period not a hundred
year period but a 10-year period and
then
there was a number of investigators who
then started to
do what you're supposed to do in science
which is replicate studies and then
often these studies didn't replicate the
classic studies 50 of the time something
like that and everyone was shocked it
was like oh my God
all these things we took for granted
it's like well first of all if you were
really a good scientist you didn't take
them for granted to begin with because
they were 10 years old
so that's not very time tested and and
second if you're has have any sense do
you think if five percent of the things
we publish in scientific journals are
true and new
we're advancing at a rate that's so
spectacular that we can already barely
keep up they think like what do you
think 95 of published science
is correct you have to be Daft to think
that it's really hard to establish a new
truth I mean think about how
revolutionary that is to do that and so
so 95 percent of Sciences
not good and 95 percent of restaurants
are subpar and like this is the way of
the world and we also don't know how
much subpar activity is necessary to
generate anything of value it might be
95 of it when think about it on the
scientific front
well
a lot of studies are published in lower
tier journals so there's thousands of
journals and so there's a hierarchy of
quality and the worst studies on average
would be published in the worst journals
but not always sometimes a really
Stellar piece of research that no one
likes which is how you can tell it's
true gets published in low tier Journal
because it's so shocking that no one
will abide by it so you need the
variation but you need the lower tier
journals because
well if you're a beginning scientist and
you're not very good at it you still
have to publish so you have to publish
somewhere that's not that good and so
and and science is very difficult
Enterprise just like any creative
Endeavor is difficult and getting to the
heart of the matter man that's
you're lucky if you do that once or
twice in your career so and it's the
same on the artistic front you know most
of it's
I think that's maybe particularly true
in the visual arts but but maybe not
most of it's subparent and
but that's okay on creating something
new there's something quite moving in
maps of meaning at the end of the book
you publish a letter or that you've
written to your father and there's a
line in it and I forget the exact line
but it's something like I I'm struggling
to articulate this but I really think
I've come across an idea
that hasn't been thought of before that
is new
and
so to what extent is your work new
the
um that's a good question
um
in in some sense it's not new at all at
all
you know it partakes of a pattern
but the articulation is new but it's
that's also it's also not
it's not also not unique to me so maps
of meaning that book it's the same book
as hero with a thousand faces it's the
same book as Jung's yeah it's the same
book as young symbols of transformation
and it's the same book as Eric Neumann's
Origins and history of Consciousness you
say it's the same you mean you don't
think you pushed the needle oh yeah
they're they're variants you know but
they're variants of a central narrative
and and there are variants of the
central narrative that's another way of
thinking about it and Campbell did a
really good job on the popularization
front you know and Jung sketched this
out more deeply than anyone else and
first and he it was symbols of
transformation that broke his
relationship with Freud it was because
Jung touched on the religious in symbols
of transformation and Freud was uh an
Enlightenment figure
and a counter-religious Enlightenment
figure and so when Jung touched on the
religious Freud believe that he was
engaged in an activity that was
antithetical to the Freudian Enterprise
which was something like the it was an
insistence on
on secularization and so they broke
apart on that issue
and
and Freud I wouldn't say Freud was wrong
because Freud was a genius I mean Freud
was the person who put the finger on the
edible issue which is like that's the
central issue of our time the devouring
mother it's like yeah she's back that's
for sure and he was the first person who
really
he really put his finger on that from a
clinical perspective like so consciously
and explicitly there'd be mythologies of
the devouring mother forever stories you
know of the witch that lived in the
forest Hansel and Gretel Perfect story
for the modern time right because there
are children who are lost well hey
that's for sure and what do they come
across well they come across a house
made of gingerbread like you know what
that's a bit too good to be true
right and so there's a witch inside and
what does she want to do well offer the
children
everything they want why so she can eat
them
yeah that's for sure and Freud he put
his finger on that
in a in a stunningly brilliant Manner
and and still a very deeply
misunderstood manner now the unions
elaborated on that Vision tremendously
Eric Neumann who wrote this book the
origins in history of Consciousness
Ultra wrote a book called the great
mother which is a compendium of the
symbolism of the feminine it's brilliant
book I talked to Camille pelia about
Eric Neumann she knew of him
independently which is quite rare among
modern
academic intellectuals I've read that
book The the
origins of Consciousness oh you have to
yeah amazing it's great he was a student
of young he was yes and and when you
wrote the forward to origins in the
history of Consciousness he said that
was the book he had been struggling to
write and Neumann was able to integrate
young root I don't know 30 books dance
difficult books Young's a very difficult
thinker
and Neumann was able to synthesize that
and both in the origins and history of
Consciousness and the great mother and
you know Cameo palia said to me and this
is a conclusion she'd reached completely
on her own and it was amazing to me
because it was a parallel to conclusion
I had reached
um for what that's worth
that if the literary critics had turned
to Neumann and Jung instead of Foucault
and ereda the whole culture War would
have
the whole
the whole situation pertaining to the
culture War would have been entirely
different
because well because
the the postmodernists got something
right
they
figured out in some real sense that
the problem of perception was
intractable
so imagine
there's a multitude of
interpretations for any given text
you have students read Macbeth and they
write 30 students write 30 essays they
all have different opinions it's like
okay well if they all have different
opinions what's the core meaning of the
text
and the answer is
we don't know but how do we come to a
determination of what the meaning is
we don't know
well could we come to a determination of
the meaning of the text well the text is
very complicated and it's subject to an
infinite variety of views so it doesn't
look like it's possible to come to a
determination of the meaning of the text
well then how do we decide which set of
texts is canonical
we don't know maybe we do it by
exercising power it's like diagnosis
correct solution wrong and that was that
Unholy marriage between post-modernism
and Marxism and there are other reasons
for it but that it was this pathological
leap from problem and it's a big problem
the problem of perception it's no wonder
the literary critics stumbled over it
but the idea that we solve the problem
of perception
by exercising power if you define power
as compulsion let's say I can make you
do what I want and that's what we're
doing as human beings is we're competing
to see who gets to make other people do
what we want and that's the basis not
only for social organization which is
the Marxist claim but for perception
itself which is certainly a claim that's
put forth by the people who
uh promote the implicit association test
for example which purports to diagnose
your implicit bias and the manner in
which power structures your say racial
perceptions
it's like and there's a huge difference
between the claim that
power
corrupt your perceptions and your
interactions and and that you have to be
alert to that and the claim that no it's
the basis of perception itself there
isn't a more there is not a more cynical
and nihilistic and corrosive claim
then the claim that power structures
your perceptions
the world is instantly at War if that's
claim is promoted because it means that
you're here for what you can get from me
now and I'm here talking to you for
purely instrumental reasons and the only
reason we get along at all even in
principle is because our Power claims
align and as soon as they don't there's
nothing between us but enmity and
struggle
and that is definitely that's the
Marxist world view in a nutshell and it
is something dark and you can tell you
know
100 million corpses have been stacked up
in a hundred years just to show you how
dark that is and then it's masked by
this clip well we're for the poor it's
like really
first of all that's not that easy
because poverty is certainly not caused
by something as simple as a lack of
money poverty is very complicated and if
you want to do something about it well
good luck to you it's very very
difficult it's easy to hand wave and say
well I stand for the oppressed it's like
yes while you maintain your position and
privilege now you're also standing for
the oppressed so not only are you
perpetrator but your victim and that's a
bit
too much for anyone to claim
simultaneously it's one of the things
that always bothered me about what has
been allowed to happen in the Ivy League
schools it's like well we're for the
oppressed it's like
you're already part of the power
structure that you hypothetically oppose
as soon as you cross the threshold into
Princeton or Yale I don't care where you
came from you're now in the one percent
now you might be a baby one percenter
you're probably more like a 1 100th of
one percenter or maybe a one one
thousandth of one percenter
so and that's not good enough for you
right being having that status and that
privilege that's not good enough you
need to also accrue all the moral virtue
that should rightly be reserved for the
truly oppressed you have to have both
because just being privileged isn't
enough you have to be privileged and
underprivileged at the same time and
then that's all facilitated by the
panderers to this juvenile narcissism
that the universities have
have become
it's appalling do you think there's any
hope for the universities
hopefully
you know and I think there are still
people who are struggling to do a
credible job and I think there are still
some credible institutions but
but they made I've watched large
remember 2008 too big to fail remember
that oh well that was the Mantra when
when the politicians were colluding with
the business types to socialize their
risk it's like well we can't let AIG
fail it's too big because systemic
disruption too big to fail it's like
that was completely it was an anti-truth
it wasn't just a lie it was like because
the truth is so big you will certainly
fail
and so
I've watched large organizations
collapse and I have some sense of how it
happens what happens first of all is
they start to shake
and then the small minority of people
who are doing all the productive work if
you have 10 000 employees 100 of them do
half the work
right that's not for Nanny
now let's say you have 10 000 employees
and your corporation has a couple of bad
quarters maybe because of bad management
decisions maybe you've got a narcissist
at the helm well the hundred people who
are awake and on their feet they think
oh
I can't do my job anymore well it's not
like they don't have options I mean
everyone knows who these people are not
just inside the company but outside they
just leave it's like the top hundred
people leave you've lost 50 percent of
your productivity
oh well then the next people who leave
are the next 25 percent of the
productivity then you're just left with
after that happens
in two or three Cycles you're just left
with people who not only can't do
anything but who think their job is to
get in the way and they're just done and
companies huge companies can collapse
unbelievably precipitously and that
happens all the time you know I think
the average lifespan of a Fortune 500
company is three 30 years and the
average lifespan of a family fortune is
three generations
and so there's lots of churn in the
upper one percent like the fact is
there's a one percent is very stable but
the people who occupy that position
churn churn to a large degree not
entirely but to a to a large degree
anyways large organizations can collapse
precipitously and they don't have to
make
much of a mistake to do that
the universities have made at least
they made a series of fatal mistakes so
they've corporatized their Endeavor so
now the students are consumers rather
than students and so they pandered to
the worst of their consumer impulses
they The Faculty retreated and left all
the
Authority in the hands of the
administrators the administrators then
retreated and left all the authority in
the hands of the die activists so that's
comical as hell to watch in a tragic and
horrible way
um they've devalued the currency because
standards have decreased uh their their
their quality of Education generally
speaking is unbelievably low
their dropout rate on average in higher
education institutions is 50 percent at
Hillsdale which is a conservative
institution it's one percent that's a
big difference 50 percent versus one
percent and 50 is utterly inexcusable uh
it's a waste of time and money but it
doesn't matter because
the institutions can still accrue the
money of the people who fail and they
don't care
so
um it seems like with the Peterson
Fellowship that you've launched and your
work with Ralston college that you're
not so hopeful to change the
institutions from within but to
do so from the outside to build well I
think one of the ways you change
institutions is by setting up
alternatives to compete with them and so
one of the things we're starting this
Peterson Academy
um which isn't a name I'm particularly
thrilled about but it has its marketing
advantages let's say and marketing is
communication and so you don't want to
be cynical about communication because
if you're doing something and no one
knows about it that's not that helpful
to your Enterprise in any case we have a
good array of professors a great array
of professors who are making eight hour
courses for us and we're hoping to
establish accreditation and I want to
drive the cost of a bachelor's degree
down to four thousand dollars
140th the current cost and I think
that's I think that can be done and
140th is a lot cheaper and I think that
we can offer now it's hard to replace a
university with with an online
Enterprise because we don't know what
universities do
and it's easy to think that what they do
is
provide facts and examinations right so
lectures and accreditation but lecturers
exams and accreditation but that's
probably five percent of what
universities truly do and the rest of it
we don't really understand so they
provide
a an intermediary between adolescents
and adulthood for creative and
intelligent people
right they provide those same people
with an identity that's socially
uh valued student well they're sorting
out the complexities of their Destiny
they move young people from what might
be a counterproductive group of peers
that's arbitrarily assigned let's say by
the public school system
to a group that is more appropriate to
their talents and their abilities they
provide a mediating place for people who
are immature to start to adopt the
responsibilities of independent
adulthood they're a place where people
can eat together they're a place where
people can drink together and have
funding to be together well there's you
know there's there's all these things
that universities are doing that is very
difficult to duplicate online and so
we're trying to wrestle with that
complexity
but on the provision of lectures and
exams in accreditation front I think we
can
give them a run for their money
and also at a very high level of quality
and uh we're trying to gather people who
love to teach and then leave them alone
it's like so there's no strictures in
some sense in our Enterprises like I'm
trying to find people who I think are
really really smart and then
inviting them to
teach what they want to teach the best
way they can and so we'll see how that
goes and then with Ralston College in
Savannah that's a more
that's a more traditional University so
it has buildings and and we run our
first we're in the midst of running our
first master's program while you and I
were just in Greece to to how was that
I mean uh unbelievable really these
students were doing four hours of
ancient Greek in the morning four hours
of modern Greek in the afternoon and
this is first of four terms of a
master's degree all the while doing day
trips to Patmos to see uh where John had
his Revelation to Ephesus to see where
Saint John came you know to preach the
logos the logos exactly
um so I mean as as far as the university
course comes like it's hard to imagine
one beating that yeah yeah well and
literally like it's literally hard to
imagine because we were both there
watching we thought well it I can't and
that's a lovely place to be you know
you're in a good place when you
literally can't imagine it being any
better not in any real sense and so yeah
that was certainly the experience in
Greece that's for sure and in turkey and
uh there's um so just to rewind one one
moment you you've criticized the
postmodern you you do it often and
um but also gave the devil is due you
know modernists were definitely on to
something they also knew that we see the
world through a story that's they just
got the story wrong just just but but
but they but it's really something to to
have noticed and and the French
intellectuals like like Foucault who is
brilliant although twisted and bent in a
terrible way but brilliant I mean
Foucault was one of the first people to
really put his finger on this and and
his his book uh the order of things the
first half of that book is brilliant it
deteriorates as it goes He it needed to
be edited more near the end what did you
find so brilliant about it
his grappling with the notion of the
structure of our conceptual structures
right he knew that we we saw the world
through a structure and he had an
intimation that it was narrative in
nature and he lays that out by analyzing
older
structures of knowledge uh
in a sense from the perspective of an
anthropologist or a psychologist he does
very much what Jung did with his work on
Alchemy it's very similar except young
derived almost completely opposite
conclusions to Foucault and Foucault
co-attis problems let's put it that way
and they definitely
tilted his thinking in a
counterproductive thing you're referring
to asexual deviants or
yes and not only in
it isn't only that it so he was he was
gay
and but that's what I was referring to
as a sexual devious by the way you know
good work that'll make you popular
deviant does mean different from the
norm right no so so
um technically that's true it means to
deviate from the path in some sense
right but I mean Foucault was also a
little bit more interested in let's say
young people than you know he might have
been which is what I was referencing yes
and and and in a manner that appears to
be
quite deeply
pathological in in a very very very very
very dark way and
well
we won't say much more about that I mean
in early in this conversation we talked
about artists not being political or not
letting uh what the artist's opinion
doesn't really matter on the art itself
the Arts but does that not apply with
Foucault to an extent where what he did
in his private life
as it was oh definitely well that's why
you actually hopefully you know it's why
because to live it is to right his
actions actually speak more for his
philosophy than his work well no at
least his actions his philosophy there's
a relation between his philosophy and
his actions now what the relation is
that's a very difficult thing to sort
out and you don't want to throw the baby
out with the bath water you know when we
look at people historical figures and
this is happening all the time we look
at someone great Francis Galton would be
a good example because he's been the
target of progressive attacks for his
hypothetical doctrines of racial
superiority which fundamentally means
that people who are attacking gold and
just never read him and no one does
although my student Daniel Higgins wrote
a thesis about Carlton and did read him
and golton was a very Galton was an
amazing person he was a polymath he's an
utter genius he made signal
contributions to like a hundred
disciplines he was really something but
he was also a man of his time and place
and a lot of intellectual scholarship
now consists of
going back over someone's biography with
a fine-tooth comb finding some way they
were in keeping with their times that
doesn't match modern sensibility and
then saying well I don't have to read
anything that person wrote It's like
well fair enough in some sense but
people do this with Freud all the time
too because Freud was a Victorian For
Better or Worse
and not everything he said jives with
modern sensibilities like well you don't
have to read Freud
but then you don't get to read Freud and
Freud is 90 percent wheat and 10 percent
chaff and 10 percent still quite a lot
but 90 percent wheat is pretty good the
typical book is one percent wheat and 99
chaff you know I often read books where
there's there's not a single idea in the
book really
you know it's it's it's it's it's a
shallow rehash of ideas that were well
established in multiple ways uh by many
people well and but Freud's not like
that the interpretation of Dreams is
there's something brilliant on every
page and man you can learn that you know
and and maybe in the same with Nietzsche
uh Nietzsche said some bitter things
about women for example and so you can
take those and you can say well who's
going to listen to him fair enough you
know don't but it's Nietzsche so that's
your loss man not his he's dead he
doesn't care
but but the idea that and it's the same
with Foucault you know I mean I'm not a
fan of glucose private life that's for
sure and I have some sense of a
clinician of just how dark it was and it
was plenty dark and did that affect his
philosophy yes I think it made him much
more attracted by Marxist doctrines of
power than he would have otherwise been
and some of that was definitely
self-serving as far as I can tell but
the order of things is a great book so
you read and you differentiate and you
discriminate just like you do when
you're talking to someone and you try to
separate the wheat from the chaff and
gather the wheat and let the child fly
away and that's that's what we do as we
move forward historically and winnow
through the past and and you don't say
because it's adulterated you don't say
it's all chaff
you know
now that's a bad idea now the
universities were that's what they were
there to teach people to do is to what
does it mean to read critically it
doesn't mean
first of all criticize doesn't mean
here's why you're wrong I dispense with
you it doesn't mean harsh attack
criticize means
analyze take what's good gather it leave
the rest that's what that's what
critical thinking means doesn't mean win
the argument
no it means
it means this unbelievably fine balance
between judgment and
between rejection and acceptance between
judgment mercy and that's the logos
that's what the logos does that's why
Christ as logos is the final judge
that's why Christ has logos in the
apocalypse dams and saves it's it's the
archetypal representation of the action
of the logos it really is
and it's doing that all the time
and so and that's happening to us all
the time
both psychologically and and
sociologically that's why the Book of
Revelation was appended to the Bible
which is so strange because it's such an
it's such a strange book right it's a
hallucinogenic Vision it it's so it's so
different from the John's gospel oh yeah
John's gospel is considered one of the
if not the greatest works of ancient
Greek writing it's perfect and then the
Revelation unfinished sentences it's all
over the place it's almost like this I
mean there's even debate that it's a
different author yeah yeah well in some
ways in some ways it is because the
Revelation is the Visionary imagination
and and
and and the Gospel of John is is
articulated philosophy I mean there's
still a theological element to it
obviously but but it but it's not much
different than the relationship between
thus spake zarathustra and the rest of
Nietzsche's writings thus speaks
zarathustra is a Visionary account
and it's if you didn't know that the
same people wrote Beyond Good and Evil
and thus this speaks arathustra you it
would be very difficult to figure it out
because the even the language is is
different and thus speak zarathustra
is
it's not unpacked it hasn't been
unpacked it's still a dream Jung ran a
seminar on thus baked zerathustra I
believe the seminar notes are 1800 pages
long and he got through the first third
and so in a vision there's there's
tremendous information packed into a
genuine Vision like almost inexhaustible
I'll give you an example if I can
it's a lot to unpack
so when God chases Adam and Eve out of
paradise
he sets up cherubim with flaming swords
to Bar the way back to Paradise
and that's a very strange image
and
and you should see it as a strange image
I mean it can imagine it painted
as an image and many people have
attempted to represent that image in
pictorial form
it's a very strange image and it's it's
either insane in some sense
whatever that means because a lot of
insanity is visionary too or you just
don't understand it at all and that's a
better
initial presumptions like you just don't
understand this at all well I can tell
you some of the things it means it's
unbelievable that this can be the case
so the cherubim
cherubim are the monsters that exist in
some sense at the base of any conceptual
structure and so as
every concept has an ideal at its Center
and a fringe
and it has to have a fringe because it
runs into other Concepts and where it
runs into other Concepts there's
ambiguity and you can see that playing
out in the debate about gender it's like
there are lots of masculine women and
feminine men
and so there's a category of masculine
male and a category of female but
there's a fringe and at The Fringe there
are chimeras
a monster is a chimera and a chimera is
a intermingling of different categories
and there are monsters at The Fringe and
that's a cherubim and it it supports an
ideal and it's like the Gargoyles on the
outside of cathedrals it's the same kind
of idea and and it's the idea of the
margin and The Fringe and and that's the
place where Unity becomes multiplicity
and part of the demand of the
postmodernists was that the multiplicity
take the center but it can't by
definition the center has to be occupied
by a Unity that's what makes it a center
in any case back to the the cherubim now
they hold swords that turn every which
way and they are on fire and they bar
the gates To Paradise well why
because
it's something like
imagine that in Paradise only what's
best exists
well that's sort of like the definition
of paradise
okay then imagine that everything about
you that isn't worthy of being in
Paradise has to go
and then imagine that that's cut away
with the Flaming sword
and that's what that means and then
there's more to it than that
so
the Flaming sword is
it's the separation of the wheat from
the chaff
and
the whole Christian narrative is
embedded in that image
that that which purifies you will also
be that which destroys you hellishly
and you see that Tangled Up in the
passion story because the passion story
is
not only encounter with tragedy in the
most fundamental sense and I mean that
technically because the passion is an
archetypal tragedy it can't be it's yet
in some real sense it's the distillation
of tragedy I'm speaking psychologically
but that's not enough because
so imagine that you will have to face
the worst things that could happen to
you well you you are going to have to
face that so that's going to happen but
to then imagine that's not enough
not only do you have to face
in order to cope
in order to become who you are even you
have to
face the worst things that are going to
happen to you but you also have to be
willing to do that and optimally
voluntarily willing to do that and maybe
even embrace it
but that's not enough you know because
the passion which is a story of torture
and innocence
that's not enough the mythology that
surrounds the passion also insists that
Christ Herod hell right so death and
catastrophe wasn't enough it had to be
hell itself and you might ask well
what's hell and the you wouldn't ask
that question if you'd ever been there
but hell is
well hell is Auschwitz you know hell is
the gulag archipelago hell is the
consequence of tyranny hell is the
spirit that drives the atrocity of
history and maybe you have to face that
too
and maybe in facing that that's the
swords that Turn and Burn and maybe that
burns everything away and that's all
embedded in that image
right at the beginning of this that
story
and so a revelation
can be so profound
that it takes
almost forever to unpack
and so and young for example
moved the process of unpacking that
forward and so did Joseph Campbell and
so did Eric Neumann and I think I hope
that I did some of that more in maps of
meaning and that that's partly what I'm
doing in my public work is unpacking
this and so you asked me originally way
back when we got into this about the
originality of my ideas and it's like
well they're not original in some sense
because they're they're based on
something that's
that manifests itself as an unbelievably
deep pattern but the pattern becomes
more explicit as it unfolds and and and
that's part of the problem part of the
process of becoming conscious itself is
the process of conscious of becoming
conscious is the process of the implicit
becoming conscious
that's like a becoming realized in
experience it's almost like a definition
of Consciousness and it might be a
definition of being which is being in
something like the manifestation into
actuality of the implicit and that's
what we participate in as conscious
beings and so and you do that as an
artist you're you're on the Forefront of
that and you don't subordinate that to
what comes later right you don't
subordinate the art to the explanation
the explanation emerges from the art if
it's a genuine explanation
and that's why we turn to artists to
even teach us to see you know every
modern person sees the World Through The
Eyes of a French impressionist
we see Beauty in the same places they
saw it and they taught us how to do that
and literally and now we see with their
eyes and thank God for artists because
they they enable us to see with the eyes
of a Visionary that's for sure so and
you don't subordinate that the political
God that's a that's a catastrophic sin
and we're doing that like mad now I
remember when reading Matthew meaning
and I was in the studio at the time uh
making a Mumford and Son's record called
Delta and
what you're saying well I really got
this from the book it's not just a
responsibility for artists well rather
um I felt like I wasn't pushing myself
into the chaos enough within myself like
looking deeply you certainly solved that
problem
yeah quite well actually on the on that
side of things and maybe this ties in
with revelation
I felt when I've been when in my by
comparison with what you've gone through
a very small version of getting
entangled in the the wars of of culture
and all this stuff that does feel like a
spiritual Onslaught and it almost feels
like Revelation and the Battle of angels
and demons and
um and I certainly remember from my mum
for her it was very painful seeing me go
through those things and she's even more
I think spiritual than I am and I
wondered whether you felt that way at
all with you know you have press and all
sorts of lies written about you
regularly and does it work like a
spiritual uh battle for you yeah but
that's probably it that's probably in
some ways
what what I say not new
in some sense it's new in that it has
been practically manifesting itself in
the world but
that was a conceptual world I already
inhabited I would sit back as early as
1985 when I started working on them the
ideas that became maps of meaning
and I I realized that this was a
psychological problem fundamentally and
uh partly because of the influence of
people like Jung and sojnitz and I think
and Orwell
uh nature
they'd already put their finger in some
real Sense on the problem
um and so but then to see it
made manifest as fate let's say out in
the world well that was that was a whole
different issue but did
I mean it became what happened around me
became
absurdly and surrealy
dramatic in a
in a
literary sense I mean that one of the
things that shocked me most I would say
just I just about fainted when I saw it
was to be cast by tenahisi coats as red
skull in the Captain America comic that
was really striking to me because I'm
very interested in archetypal stories
I've watched all the Marvel movies and
of course all the Harry Potter movies
very interested in popular culture and
the Marvel Universe
which is a theological Universe
obviously
like obviously as is the Harry Potter
universe
um
has a huge it's a huge hugely
influential cultural force and quite
counter-cultural the the Marvel world is
very non-politically correct it's quite
remarkable well so is is so is uh JK
Rowling's World
um but not for political reasons either
of them which is why they've been so
spectacularly successful but Captain
America is a you know a central
archetypal Trope and to be cast as Red
Skull was just it was just beyond belief
when I first saw the comic I thought
that was Photoshop and then to find out
that it wasn't and then to find out that
easy quotes wrote it it was like what
the hell is going on here it was so over
the top to not only be cast as a Nazi
but to be cast as
like literally the magical satan-like
source of Nazism itself it was it was so
over the top and it was very difficult I
was very sick when it was happening too
like I would have much rather have been
dead than to be as sick as I was and to
have that happen on top of that was just
it was just too much and uh
it took us a couple of weeks my family
to figure out how to
Parry that thrust let's say and which
we're quite happy with we we this check
kid sent me a an illustration so the the
uh the Hydra organization has a logo
which is I believe it's a spider
and it's black on red and the two most
primary colors black red and white are
the fundamental primary colors of human
perception so black and red
and uh he turned it into a lobster and
did a very lovely job
and we thought that was very funny and
he sent it to us and so then we thought
oh well we could we could make lobster
Hydra merchandise and sell it for
charity that'd be funny it was funny and
so we made this symbol with this Lobster
Hydra in the middle
and uh said we put the words tell the
truth and clean up your room around it
and then we sold t-shirts and all sorts
of things and we raised like half a
million dollars for charity which was
that was good that worked real well
because it was a bit it was a bit
humorous you know it's hard to be to
have a sense of humor in a situation
like that just but it's the only way out
well it's the optimal Way Forward if you
can do it and to play a bit with it you
know but it's very hard to play with
accusations of satanic possession public
accusations of satanic possession but it
was a relief in some sense I would say
because like well that's
that's the limit of reputational assault
it's like where do you go from there
there's no place past that so that was
in some sense that was the end of that
for me because at any
assault that's
subsequent to that
just like the Olivia Wilde thing we we
thought that was amusing pretty much
right away and I don't think I would
have thought that at all four years ago
well you know what this is like I've met
150 people who've been publicly mobbed
almost all of them
foreign
it's very unsettling to people it's it's
really the equivalent of a very very
serious illness it's really hard on
people and I've seen extremely stable
people
admirable people well put together just
brought to the lowest extreme by that
public shaming it's an unbelievably
vicious weapon and we've enabled it with
our social media networks in a manner
that we may pay a very big price for it
you've you've you've been through no uh
and and for me it was as well as
everything else I lost a ton of weight
and I wasn't sleeping for months and it
was it's totally hellish and I've
interviewed people punch people in on
this podcast series about this and no
it's not enjoyable for anyone it's hot
it's absolutely oh no even even well you
said what happened to you was relatively
minimal and it wasn't because you know
you're a pretty public figure and it was
pretty public and it cost you a lot and
so you went through you went through it
pretty hard
I've seen people who've gone through it
you know sort of at their level of
social prominence
you know professors who've been attacked
by student newspapers and their
colleagues let's say which which isn't
happening on the same public scale as
as what happened to you
um but they
they respond to it
well look people have two categories of
fear really fear of nature which is
death and Insanity like you know your
own body betraying you and
at an age all of that that ravages of
nature but the second category of fear
is social alienation and then those
things are tangled up because
historically if you were shunned you
were also dead right because as soon as
that social protection is stripped
against you away from you especially if
it's also turned against you you don't
have a hope and so people this is partly
why people are conformist and that's not
all
cowardice a lot of it's
well generally you should go along with
it yeah there's a lot I sympathize I've
got so many messages about people
self-centering when when I went through
my stuff and and actually it's it's not
they have families they have these
structures oh yeah those aren't nothing
and they are worth and I actually admire
a lot of people who decide actually you
know what I'm going to sacrifice
saying my piece here because I'm going
to put my family first or I'm going to
put my record and there's there's great
dignity
the problem with that is so it means
that these ideas that become taboo then
sort of win because yeah yeah well the
worst conflicts are moral conflicts like
real conflicts of Duty so you might say
well you have a responsibility to
keep a civil tongue in your head so to
speak just to speak the truth but then
if you're in a situation where people
are going to come after your family
because of your opinion then what do you
sacrifice and the answer is well you're
going to make whatever bad decision
you're capable of making at that point
and it's often well I'm not going to put
my family at risk now
that's not optimal
the question then becomes what's the
alternative and the alternative is when
you're in that situation well first of
all to prepare yourself so that if
you're ever in that situation you have
some options you actually have a chapter
about this in your uh 12 more rules for
that yeah in Beyond order yes yes well I
dealt with a lot of people who had been
bullied into a mental health crisis at
work a lot of people in fact part of the
reason I made my first public
pronouncement to say on Bill c-16
the compelled speech law in Canada was
because twenty percent of my clinical
clients were there because they were
being bullied by
um narcissists of compassion at work and
they hadn't come to me because of my
political stance this was before
anything was known about me at all
politically that's just it was a sign of
the times and that was very worrisome
social workers
um corporate employees lawyers uh
doctors was manifesting itself uh people
in Academia was manifesting itself
across a wide range of disciplines I
even had mothers saying it which I
couldn't understand what kind of
workplace whether it's maybe it's family
groups or whatever yeah they couldn't or
mother's groups yeah mothers groups yeah
because they can be viciously viciously
competitive about who's the most
compassionate and so yeah that's that
that can be very awful but um do you
think there's a good side to the
compassionate
so the social justice movement where do
they get it right do you think there
there is an aspect where we do need to
well someone love our neighbor and yeah
someone has to speak for the approach
what's a healthy way of doing that
well I think partly that's that's what
you strive to learn your whole life
what a healthy way of doing that is I
mean the one of the core tenets of
Christian theology is that the highest
should serve the lowest
it's not that's not even right it's not
should it's that what is truly highest
manifests itself most precisely in
service to the lowest
and that's that's exemplified for
example by by the uh
by Christ washing his disciples feet for
example right so he's he's he's he's
he's taking what's highest and using it
to serve what's lowest and that was
particularly relevant in that culture
because
if I remember correctly and I think this
is still true in some Arab cultures you
don't show people the bottom of your
feet because it's it's it's like toilet
behavior in some sense you know it's
that's in touch that's part of you
that's in touch with
what's contaminating and to serve that
is it's like taking care of the lepers
it's it's like taking care of the
outcasts and
um
it is the
obligation
and maybe the privilege of what's
Sovereign to serve the lowest in fact
that's then this is one of the things
that so Revel utterly revolutionary
about
the thought that manifests itself in
Christian theology is that that what is
truly highest is that which serves
the most
the most
those in the most Dire Straits and that
that's a very remarkable conception of
sovereignty it's certainly not power
it's it's the antithesis of power in in
the most real sense and it it's it's not
obvious either because it's completely
revolutionary pain before there's
nothing so it turned what came before
completely on its head it's the most
radical thinking and and it hasn't I
don't think been surpassed since yeah
well in some sense it can't be
surpassing I suppose in in some sense
that's the definition of divine wisdom
right it's wisdom that cannot be
surpassed and so now the thing about
service to the outcast is that
it's not reflexive compassion
those are not the same thing whatever
virtue is is a very complex dynamic
balance of many many sub-virtues only
one of which is compassion now you might
say is there a laneway for untrammeled
compassion and the answer to that is yes
care of infants
and so because
an infant from birth to six months say
is
always right
their complaints are always to be
regarded as true they're always to be
attended to as a first priority it's
actually a precondition for proper
development
and I I was always I was quite Amazed by
my wife's maternal capacity my wife is
quite a tough person and she doesn't
have a lot of pity let's say for useless
men
quite the contrary but she's
unbelievably responsive to infants and
so when Michaela was first born I had
built this bed we lived in a small
apartment in Montreal and I built this
bunk bed out of two by fours
because it was stood an earthquake this
thing it was very strong and we so we
built a platform bat in this small room
we had and we built Michaela crib
underneath and so we'd sleep above her
and uh at night if Michaela would just
stir and make a noise maybe indicative
of discomfort or hunger Tammy would be
instantly up down the stairs and
attending to that baby even before she
woke up it was quite remarkable it
wasn't something that I was wired to do
that's for sure and she would generally
have Michaela soothed fed or or dealt or
or the source of discomfort removed
maybe she was too hot or too cold or
something was you know bothering her
that she couldn't move away from she'd
fix that so quickly that the baby
wouldn't even wake up and so it was
perfect responsiveness but um
but you know Tammy was also wise enough
so that as her children
matured she could step away from that
all-encompassing maternality that's
properly directed towards infants and
start to be more judicious more
judgmental which is what you have to
become as your children mature because
you you have to set a standard for their
behavior that expands as they mature and
so that brings judgment into Mercy right
and judgment Mercy are the twin hands of
God in some sense and to say that God's
hand is only Mercy well that if it's
only Mercy well then it's the devouring
mother that's Mary gone seriously wrong
and that judgment coming back sorry
Revelation at the end of the Bible is
almost like a little bit of judgment
interjected into the New Testament that
was Young's comment on the psychological
um real re reason in the broadest sense
why Revelation was accepted as
canonicals because
he he believed that the image of Christ
that was put forth in the gospels tilted
hard towards the merciful now it's not
only Mercy because Christ flips the
money changers tables for example and
goes after the Pharisees and the scribes
pretty hard but in Revelation the
judgmental aspect of the logos is much
more
it's much more front and center and it's
it's quite a damning vision in some
sense unless you happen to be among the
elect let's say and and
well you know time will tell so to speak
whether that's true
so but that compatible you said you know
is there a place for compassion it's
like yes yes there is but everything in
its proper place and it's a very complex
problem I mean one of the issues that
Jung returned to repeatedly and you see
this in the Harry Potter stories too
so there's a trinitarian structure in
Christianity but for Jung that meant
there was a missing quadrant because he
believed that General
revelatory visions of totality like the
vision of paradise which is a circle
divided into four parts Two Rivers
coming from a central point Paradise is
a Mandela divided into four parts that's
Northeast west and south that's the
whole world
there's a missing quadrant in
Christianity
and it's filled either by Mary or Satan
and they argue for priority in some
sense as a to provide a fully fledged
out vision of of the Transcendent and
you see that in the Harry Potter stories
with the houses because the fourth house
is Slytherin and the the the the the the
champion of Slytherin in some sense is
Snape and Snape has his role but there's
also ambivalence there with Hermione
like what's her position exactly because
in some sense she's the wisest of the of
the heroes right but she's feminine and
so
she's she's she fleshes out the story as
does Slytherin and Snape but there's
it's a very difficult
combination it's even the serpent it's
very difficult combination to integrate
into the into the complete vision
and so and and Rowling did a very good
job of that I mean her books are
remarkable she has an unbelievably
accurate Visionary imagination she's she
managed
narratives in that book that are almost
unbelievably deep the the uh the game
the Quidditch game narrative is
unbelievably deep I can't figure out how
she figured that out
but I think she has an unerring
Visionary imagination like like William
Blake no she's a real Visionary and
you know you might say well it's just
entertainment it's like look man this
woman came from nowhere and she's richer
than the queen she's like the major
British export all by herself
um she she
enticed tens of millions of children to
read 700 page books many of them she
spoke to stadiums full of children and
their families she spawned on an entire
entertainment industry which then turned
on her on the movie front which was
utterly appalling and unforgivable and
so narcissistic and so ungrateful and uh
and but her imagination is
is unerring like the the Quidditch game
it has two tiers say
so the ordinary quidditch I'll probably
get some of the details wrong is it's
kind of like basketball or soccer played
on brooms it's just a game every
everyone can understand it but on top of
the game there's a meta game and that's
the game The Seekers play and The
Seekers follow this Golden Ball that
shimmers and moves and that's an
alchemical symbol that round ball it's
the round chaos and it's the container
of possibility and it's associated with
the
the symbol of mercury and Mercury is the
winged messenger of the Gods and Mercury
is Mercurial and Mercury gathers gold
and Mercury literally the metal mercury
gathers gold if you mix Mercury with
gold ore it takes the gold to it and so
is very complicated symbolic domain of
representation and Rowling's intuition
was that
the Seeker wins the Seeker by seeking
and
and following what glimmers and and
dances and that's the artistic
inclination to follow what glimmers and
dances is the successful Seeker wins all
the games and she put that all in that
she just packed all of that into this
little side Narrative of quidditch it's
stunning and and and to use that image
that winged ball that's a really old
image and it's really obscure and what
it means is not obvious and she got it
right she got a dead on it's really
something it's a it's a it's a kind of
Miracle of of intuition have you had
interactions with her no no we've we've
we've made I've made some attempts to
reach out to her she's responded
um peripherally
we haven't met
and I don't know the reasons but one of
the reasons is she's well has things to
do but she's also busy writing and so
but I would like to talk to her because
I would like to find out how she felt
Her Way Forward while making these
stories because she has an unerring
vision and so that's that's very
interesting yeah and it's a culturally
significant phenomenon I mean she filled
a massive theological void
and very effectively and and and and the
books are delightful and do this book is
is actually pertains to this
conversation we've had because it's
about being mobbed by uh trans activists
and so she's turned it and this is
actually a wonderful thing is she's
turned that experience into something
beautiful into well I haven't read it so
but I'm assuming it's beautiful and and
turning it into art which is which is
very encouraging it's it's leading by
example
she's she's obviously uh she's she's got
a spine of Steel that woman now you
could say well you know she has the
money to allow herself to do this like
do not confuse security with courage
those are not the same thing and I've
watched people for years in privileged
and secure positions professors let's
say who are as secure as anybody can
possibly be made in this world and the
notion that as soon as you're secure
enough you become courageous it's like
that no that that no it's you've got
more to lose backwards you've got more
to lose so well you've also sacrificed
you may have sacrificed your integrity
already
in many many ways to attain that
position of security it's not like you
were practicing being brave
so yeah yeah and security doesn't make
people Brave that obviously
because if you're if you're speaking
only in a from a position of security
there's nothing Brave about that
I mean it might be brave if someone else
did it but if you bear no risk
then that's not great and and
I I haven't seen at all that people who
are more well protected from the
vicissitudes of existence
are braver in consequence I I don't see
any evidence for that the the the in in
defense of that though I uh in my
experiences I I did feel well I can
afford to
go through this and I felt for a lot of
people who couldn't afford who couldn't
afford to you know they have mortgages
to pay or rent to pay so yeah in that
sense it would have been more brave for
someone with that sort of pressure I'm
not convinced I'm not convinced because
you had different things to lose and you
had different sources of stability and
one of your sources of stability was
financial and you did have that on your
side but when people are put into a
corner and push comes to shove they have
their advantages and they have the cost
that they have to pay and it isn't
obvious to me that that's that different
between people now I do understand that
some people are in unbelievably
straightened circumstances and you might
say well they can't afford to be
virtuous but my observation has been
that I have met people in unbelievably
straightened circumstances who had
nothing going for them in a way that you
could par hardly possibly imagine who
were nonetheless Brave and virtuous and
and I've met some very damaged people
God people who were basically
they're outcasts in every way street
living on the street
with a serious mental illness with a
pathological family
alcoholic and psychotic
um with an with who are ill who were
intellectually impaired
who are physically unattractive
who are uneducated all at once
who were virtuous and brave
and so there there's an independence of
position
there's an independence of position for
moral virtue in a very very very
fundamental sense I met other people too
who were brutalized so badly as children
that you can't listen to their stories
without weeping
who decided that they would nonetheless
put them their lives together and move
forward
and so I think that's
that's the choice everybody makes and in
some sense
that's an equal choice
you know now I understand you know you
had the financial resources
when this all happened
so that one thing you weren't going to
lose was your financial security Maybe
right but and that is definitely
something you had in your corner but
people have various things in their
Corner including the Integrity of their
soul and I've seen people as I said a
struck are struck dumb with admiration
for some of my most
alienated and struggling clients who
would still
is heartbreaking
we're still even in there absolute
catastrophe of their existence
be motivated to find someone who yet had
it worse and help them
unbelievable
and
that that speaks to this the central
equivalence of value of human beings in
some fundamental sense and and also the
similarity of their moral obligations
it's really something it's it really
changed me watching that in my most
in the clients I had who had the most
difficult lives and I had a very wide
range of clients ranging from people who
were hyper successful you know in
multiple Dimensions to people who were
so demolished that
it was a constant Miracle of Revelation
how much trouble surrounded them and and
that they were in
and still
many of the people who were in
privileged positions made Elementary
errors that really hurt them and many of
the people who were
barely hanging on to the Ragged edge of
disaster
made the right decisions so it's
something to see man
given this climate that we've described
a little bit
I wondered if there's a Jordan Peterson
prediction so if dostersky said
socialism would kill 100 million if
Nietzsche said that we've killed God and
there won't be enough water to mop up
the blood what's your prediction for the
future what do you see
well I I've thought this for quite a
long time but but it's more obvious now
um
will either
subject ourselves to an internal or an
external
approximation of the Apocalypse
and so we can either get our act
together which means to voluntarily
subject ourselves to the Flaming sword
as an individuals or that will be
impressed upon us as a necessity from
without and how intense that will get
we're going to find out because it's
coming very fast and this is going to be
a rough winter
and we've done everything we could to
make it rough because this is
whatever happens this winter
is pretty much 100
self-inflicted yeah so your hair is a
political reference you're you're making
then about the energy energy crisis and
inflation and and it was specifically
specifically the energy issue because
it was absolutely obvious that what's
going to what's happening right now was
going to happen was if you had your eyes
open vaguely for the last 10 years
thought oh I see where that's headed
and now we're there and why because we
went there
so and we we did that as moral postures
do you see any any hope then or do you
see any anyone with the leadership to to
navigate us through that so well we'll
see you know I've met lots of great
people who who have true leadership
ability a lot of that true leadership
ability
uh is what true leaders do
just so everyone knows
um is they go and listen to people
like really listen what's your problem
what's your problem what's your problem
and then they aggregate all the problems
then at least they know what the
problems are and then they they listen
what do you want what would you what
would you like to see as an alternative
they aggregate all that
and then that's a bottom-up movement in
some real sense like well here's the
problems what everyone's saying here's
the commonalities across what they're
saying here's what people would want
well then the leaders figure out how to
make that happen and then people are
happy because it matches their needs now
that can become corrupt because if
you're having problems you can look for
someone to blame and that's that's the
process that
the left Wingers accused the
right-wingers of uh manifesting in the
form of populism right and I think that
was one of Trump's Temptations was to
listen to the problems manifest
themselves as resentment
and then offer a solution
based on resentment and the left Wingers
do that too obviously and perhaps even
more egregiously
but that's not a good solution
a solution is a better vision
and do we have leaders that can provide
that
we're struggling
for a better vision
and I would say a lot of the activism on
the left to give the devil its due is
also the struggling for a better Vision
the notion that we should be stewards of
the environment which is a much better
way of conceptualizing it
uh caretakers
conservists and servers yeah yeah you
think the conservances would embrace it
more right right well tenders of the
garden right keepers of the garden
that's our divine
obligation let's say that there's
something in that that part of what
drives the environmentalist ethos
on the positive front the negative front
is something like you know human beings
are a cancer on the planet and we're the
spoilers of Nature and
we're viewed as empathetical to the
Natural order instead of
an emergent part of the natural order
and uh were were obliged to shoulder a
like an anti-nihilist burden of guilt
for violating the natural order and like
you can see an Impulse in that too
to tending but but you can also see it's
War it it being warped in a terrible way
by
by guilt and shame and
accusation and
and envy and
the desire for revenge on God for
creating such an appalling Place let's
say and that's what it is most
fundamentally and that's the spirit of
Cain
and so
on a
more positive note you had a very
wonderful video because this week here
in London we are mourning the death of
our Monarch the queen and your Monarch
as well as a Canadian and there's a
wonderful video where you really praise
the institution and its significance
which I urge listeners to to find for
themselves but I wondered whether as a
Canadian and as she was your head of
state as well whether you had a personal
uh
fondness for her as a as a woman as a as
your queen certainly admiration for her
and fondness likely to the degree that
you can be fond of someone who exists in
some sense as an abstraction
um
or it I think you have to be a fool not
to admire Queen Elizabeth you have to be
an envious fool
you have to be unable or unwilling to
put yourself in her shoes
um people many are bitterly carping
about her privilege it's like
she lived in a she lived in a
in a zoo she lived in a magnifying
chamber I went and met a soccer player a
football player this week Ronaldo
Cristiano very glad you brought that out
because as a Manchester United fan that
was uh the thing I wanted to ask you but
we know we talked a bit about his life
and he really in some sense can't go out
because he's so famous
and so nothing in his life is
[Applause]
he doesn't have the advantages of
someone who's ordinary let's say well
there's no advantages to being ordinary
it's like
yeah there is you can walk down to your
local pharmacy
that's a big advantage
and Ronaldo doesn't have that and you
say well he's got his fortune and he
does and and he deserves it as far as
I'm concerned and but he lives a
circumscribed light and his life is
nowhere near as circumscribed as the
Queen's life was I mean she was on
display
she had to be on her best behavior every
single place she went
from the time she was in her early
twenties for 70 years
always on her best behavior and you
think well you think you could imagine
in your situation where hardly anyone's
looking at you at all you're on your
best behavior all the time are you I
don't think so you think you could have
done what she did and then you accuse
her of
like this unearned privilege it's like
her life was one
look I'm sure she had a wonderful
Adventure you know and more power to her
for that but her life was one of service
clearly we don't even know
who she was
and that's as it should be
you know now we know you know we can
infer she was a conscientious person she
was emotionally stable
she was
she had a nice balance of agreeable and
disagreeable because she was not a
pushover
but she was a caring person
she was reserved I would say she was
somewhat introverted she wasn't
spectacularly creative and that might be
just as well in a monarch you know
because as a traditional Force Charles
is more creative I think than Elizabeth
and that's possibly to his detriment now
we'll see because that could be
integrated but it's complicated when
you're
a traditional icon to be creative
because those aren't the same thing but
and so you you can infer Elizabeth's
personality and uh but we really don't
know
who she was and that's because
she kept what was Private to herself and
don't complain don't explain very much
her mentoring yeah and and we were
talking about this before we started um
recording but in an age where where
privilege is the cardinal sin and yet
monarchy I think uh has an 80 to 85
approval rating in the in this country
and that and you were saying this is
perhaps because of her the way she
sacrificed her life to Serve the People
well well exactly I think I think that
Elizabeth atoned for her privilege
right and I think we all have to do that
and I think part of the criticism of
privilege that's emerging
out of the left
to give the devil it's due his do once
again is that
privilege demands a commencement
responsibility but that needs to be
universalized because as modern people
we're more privileged than any people
who have ever lived by a large margin
now I think the average family deemed as
below the poverty line in the United
States has two vehicles
and almost all of them have air
conditioning and a non-substantial
minority a non-trivial minority have
swimming pools
and so
poverty in the United States and I'm not
saying there aren't poor people in the
United States and I'm not saying there
aren't disenfranchised people but that
often has it's a lot more complicated
often than mere lack of money
we have a lot of privilege in the modern
world
especially in the West
and we need to atone for that and atone
means at one that's the word at one
that has to be aimed at
something sufficiently high so that the
privilege
is Justified and what that means in some
sense is that as you have more
as as you've been granted more because
that's your privilege what you've been
granted you are morally obligated to
take on more responsibility
and you might say well why should I and
the answer to that is well first of all
if you don't your conscience will
torture you
second if you don't end your conscious
conscience torments you and the mob
comes for you you will convict yourself
right and be unable to mount a defense
third fourth you'll find that the
privilege
if it's not accompanied by a
commencement responsibility will be
Hollow and counterproductive and so
you'll be nihilistic and desperate in a
sea of Plenty and none of that's a good
none of that's good
and so that Demand on the left for
privilege to be held accountable
there is an element of that that's
properly
manifest but a huge amount of it is
contaminated with like a presumptuous
and narcissistic envy and an insistence
that anyone who has any more than anyone
else which generally means any more than
me has only accrued it through theft
it's like well if the person who has
more than you only accrued it through
theft
and you have more than anyone
like anyone you could speak of any
particular person so there's some person
out there who you have more than
well did you not steal it too
so how why can that accusation not be
levied against you well I don't mean
people like me it's like yeah that's
convenient for you I went to this
Hollywood uh
lecture once
it was in a very rich Hollywood
neighborhood we were sitting on this
lawn that sloped down over the Hollywood
Hills
looking at the Star City and the
background it was really beautiful and
the woman who was lecturing to this
crowd of about 200
wealthy people by by any standard was
talking about the one percent and it was
so comical and at the end I stood up and
said I don't know
if you notice but
you're the one percent clearly and if
you don't know it it's like
well look around
well they didn't think so because they
thought they were like at the 95th
percentile and then there's the five
percent well and it's it's not trivial
right because maybe you're a millionaire
but you're not a billionaire and even if
you're a billionaire you're not Elon
Musk like there are there are tiers of
privilege above you and so it's really
easy for you to think well you're the
place where victimization starts your
tier is where victimization starts Me
and Everyone lower than me we're the
victims and everyone above is the
thieves it's like well you know go two
or three layers down and you're
indistinguishable from the billionaires
to someone who
you know for whom the ability to buy a
glass of Coca-Cola is a sign of almost
unimaginable social status and that's
probably the case for maybe two billion
people in the world
so we have no idea how
much in the west we're all in the one
percent and certainly by historical
standards and so we have plenty to atone
for and we're being called upon to do it
right shoulder the burden of historical
atrocity
well
back to Cristiano Ronald Cristiano
Ronaldo if I may because I'm a huge man
united fan and how did that come about
what what was it like meeting him what
was what's he what's he thinking what's
what's in his mind is he a fan of yours
is he red maps of me he had some he had
some his family went through some
difficult times a few months ago and uh
he someone
forwarded him one of my lectures and he
started watching them and and then he
started to read 12 rules for life and he
said it was very helpful and so he
reached out to me uh had heard through
the grapevine I suppose that I would be
in Manchester and so he reached out to
me and I thought well that sounds like
fun and so I went out to his house and
we talked for about two hours about
mostly as it turned out we talked about
his the details of his current career
and spent most of the time strategizing
so that was very fun and
you know he's quite a remarkable person
as far as I could tell very youthful
looking which is relevant because he's
kept himself in very good shape which he
has to because he's 37 and still playing
football at a very high level so you
know he's had to attend to himself
physically he's very disciplined
um I found him very open and gracious he
clearly loves his wife he's a very very
astute businessman he's super smart as
far as I could tell
not surprising at all apart from you
know his god-given natural Talent it's
not surprising at all that he's who he
is and he was one of those people you
meet you think yeah yeah kind of figures
you're you're
who you are like all the way to the Core
and uh so we had a very productive
time together and uh the time flew he
said you know he wasn't sure what we
were going to talk about and I wasn't
sure I mean I'm a Canadian and so do you
know what what of his your lectures that
he appealed to him was it the biblical
series was it was it uh something
specific I don't know specifically no I
didn't I didn't ask him about the
specifics
um I think
I think if I had to guess it would be
the lectures pertaining to the
sustaining meaning of responsibility
and proper action in the face of tragedy
I I suspect that that would be the theme
that was that was productive but I don't
know specifically
um well I would have loved to have been
a fly on the wall but uh well I'd like
to ask you uh well I've got a few more
questions but I'll ask you one more
question
um you're uh you're writing a book we
who wrestle with God and I guess this
ties back to my earlier question and the
note you wrote in maps of meaning to
your father saying you you you're
struggling to articulate these ideas and
in the 23 years that have have gone
since Master meaning do you feel like
you're closer to articulating those
ideas and is this well I'm practicing
that all the time you know each of the
lectures is an opportunity to push that
capacity to articulate a little further
to make it a little more differentiated
to make it a little more accessible to
make it make it clearer and so and it's
an unfolding right because the ideas
well first of all they're not my ideas
but the ideas were implicit and then
they unfold right maybe they unfold
first of all in Revelation and then they
unfold in art and then they unfold in
narrative and then they unfold in
philosophy and then they unfold in
apprehensible public speech it's
something like that and it's a constant
unfolding and so you know I'm for me I'm
on the edge of my ability to do that
unfolding and that's the edge that I
occupy and I think the reason that my
lectures are successful by lectures
they're not really lectures they're
conversations with the crowd in some
real sense but the reason they're
successful is because it
they offer people an opportunity to
participate in the process of that
unfolding because it's not it's not only
unfolding for me in some sense it's
unfolding for those two with whom I'm
communicating
at the same time and the lectures
the public events are a place for that
to happen you know you know it's the
same thing in some real sense that
you're doing when you're playing your
music you know you're
you're having
you know an idea is unfolding you have
you feel the energy and you see what
resonates and right you see what
resonates it's a conversation right
right right right and you know when a
concert goes great the audience is the
same place you are and everyone is doing
the same thing it's a form of collective
worship fundamentally in celebration and
celebration of what well it's the
unfolding of an artistic Vision
obviously because that's what you're
doing on stage and
um and and and there's an
improvisational element to that which is
why people like live concerts uh and a
participatory element and I would say
the same thing applies
to my public engagements and and it's
it's extremely it's demanding but it's
extremely
um engaging you know very so we who
wrestle with God then will that be a
distillation of your public speaking in
in a book
it'll and and with the advantage to a
book is that you can really it's really
rigorous
and so it's it's a distillation that
that's that's that's that's a good way
of thinking about it's a further
development of the ideas that I
developed in maps of meaning and then
unfolded in my last two books and this
is this will be
further way further into the frontier
like I've made leaps in this book that
goal I would say far beyond
what I managed in maps of meaning and
there's much more original thought in
this book than there is in 12 rules or
Beyond order because those books were
really
popularizations in some sense
of the concepts that I developed in maps
of meaning and I was able to make them
more apprehensible because I spent 20
years lecturing about Maps meaning and
so I learned how to communicate the
ideas in a manner that was
grippable and but with this new book we
who wrestle with God
I I I have a cardinal idea
um
that
it's a revolutionary idea
now it's not my idea in the same sense
we've already been talking about it's
the unfolding of something that's being
implicit and but but I think I've
unfolded it a nice another another layer
that's very exciting so I I can give you
like an overview in some sense well
you act out a story and not only do you
act out his story
but you perceive the world through a
story
and so then the question is well what
story
should you act out
and so then you might think
of that is what story should you emulate
or you might think about it as what
story should you imitate now there's
hints of that in darkness like the
imitation of Christ let's say but
anyways what should you imitate well you
should imitate
that which is the highest well is that a
description of the objective world it's
like no because you can't imitate the
objective world
not obviously
it's complicated but not obviously you
imitate something like a spirit
right you which is a pattern of behavior
that's a that's a way of thinking about
a spirit it's a pattern of behavior so
you might say well if you're in a
concert that whole audience is animated
by a spirit it's the spirit of music
whatever that spirit is and it inhabits
everybody simultaneously and it's
obviously a pattern because everyone's
moving the same way it's a pattern right
and there's Saint physiologically like
the band is synced together
physiologically you know and there's
something moving about that literally
because it moves you well
there's a pattern that you should
emulate
it's a pattern of character and the
stories about God in the biblical Corpus
are
representations of the pattern to
emulate they're not a description of the
structure of the objective world they're
not proto-scientific theories they're an
embodied ethos and it's very complex
ethos because you might say well who
should you be well you can't sum it up
in a sentence because life is too
complicated to sum up in a sentence
um you could say love your neighbor as
thyself if you had to sum it up in a
sentence but still that has to be
unpacked God is presented in the
biblical Corpus as a character
and as a character that calls to
to emulate I'll give you a couple of
examples so for example
in the story of Noah God is presented as
the spirit that calls to the wise in
times of trouble to prepare
you might say well do you believe in God
he's like well do you let that spirit
guide you well you do if you're wise and
awake
do you believe well it depends on what
you mean by belief if you follow the
spirit that calls you when you're wise
to prepare in times of Crisis then you
believe
in the most fundamental sense because
you acted out and you see the world well
and then God is represented
as a character with multiple dimensions
and each story is a representation of a
dimension so another example in the
Abraham story which is a very
fundamental story
uh God is represented as the spirit that
calls the
overly dependent and secure to the
adventure of their lives
say Do you believe in that it's like
well do you leave your place of security
and have the adventure of your life yes
or no no then you don't believe yes then
you follow that Spirit that's the belief
is the following it's not a
propositional statement it's the
following then in the story of Exodus
God is the spirit that calls those who
labor under tyranny to
shoulder the burden and responsibility
of their autonomy it's like do you
believe in that
well figure that out for yourself it's
like
do you think slavery is wrong well of
course it's wrong it's obvious that it's
wrong it's like yeah well there's a
reason it's obvious and it isn't because
you figured it out
it's and it's and it wasn't obvious to
many people throughout the vast spans of
history in fact quite the opposite was
obvious it's like if I can make you do
what I want why don't I have the right
to do that or why isn't that even the
definition of right
it's like that's a really hard question
and modern people and I would say that's
particularly true of people on the left
they just recoil it it's obvious that
slavery is wrong really it's that
obvious is it why did it take us until
like 500 years ago to figure that out
then if it's so obvious
and and so well so part of this book is
an investigation into the character
of God so to speak and viewed not
entirely through the lens of the
biblical Corpus but
to a large degree and so
and it's an investigation the title we
who wrestle with God that's what Israel
means the word Israel means we who
wrestle with God which is really
something because Israel
the people of Israel are God's chosen
people and what that implies at a
narrative level is that if you wrestle
with God you're one of the chosen people
and everyone wrestles with God
whether they know it or not
and so
and that's true even more for atheists
than for most religious people because
they spend almost all their time
wrestling with God
they wouldn't Proclaim themselves as
atheists otherwise they'd be off you
know chasing girls or something which
probably is what they should be doing
but the end of demons and dostoesky
talks about but it's better to be off
the fence not believing yeah God than on
the fence you know as an agnostic yeah
yeah and well that and you see that in
the Book of Revelation too because
Christ says very straightforwardly in a
division of Christ uh is accompanied by
the sentiment the that
those who sit on the fence are those who
will be subject to the harshest judgment
yeah yeah because you want to play both
hands against the middle eh and that's
just you never commit then and then you
never learn and then you're done so at
least if you're an atheist it's like
you're going hard at the problem you
know that's why I admire people like
Dawkins and and Harris I was going to
ask this actually and it's a question
that I meant to us earlier because
you've criticized the the postmodernists
often but I wondered about the The Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse the new
atheists yeah well Douglas Murray was
sort of in that camp sure yeah and he
was Hitchens his uh uh Protege in a
sense and and yeah Hitchens Harris
Dennis and and Dawkins that in a way
that you might one might if you might
like to describe them as as people doing
as Nietzsche said killing God you know
just trying to get rid of him and I
wondered if you thought that they had
had any uh blood in their hands like the
postman it's or rather what damage do
you think they've reaped or have hooked
on on on the institutions we've
discussed and well you know I I I like
Sam Harris and we've gone along real
well and I think Sam's a good guy
fundamentally I think he's trying really
hard to be a good guy
um
I think that he's obsessed with the
problem of transcendent evil
and that's like three quarters of the
way to a religious Revelation in some
fundamental sense he he's also spent a
lot of time in recent years on his
meditation app and he's taken a side
journey into Eastern mysticism and there
are reasons for that I don't think Sam
wants to
develop a religious belief that his
critical intellect could demolish and so
as long as he leaves the Transcendent
ineffable he can have a relationship
with it and so I can understand that and
uh
and Dawkins I learned Lots from Dawkins
I I liked his biological work I mean
it's very reductionistic but
hey man if you can reduce something
complex to something simple and you can
do it more power to you and what are the
limits of that like I I think that
Dawkins
I don't think Dawkins
look Dawkins is very smart so you have
to criticize someone like that very
carefully I don't he's told me that I
was drunk on symbols and I would say
well he's parched drunk on symptoms
drunk on symbols yeah but but and he's
parched on and he's parched without them
you know but but it's also temperamental
difference you know a lot of scientists
bounce off young
because they they're not Visionary in
their imagination and many scientists
aren't because science is actually an
algorithmic process and Dawkins is a
very good scientist but he's not a
visionary
um even I shouldn't even say that quite
because his concept of memes is so close
to the concept of archetype that you
just have to tap it it would fall into
that category
archetype the union ID archetype is like
a meta meme it's way deeper than the
idea of me because a meme like an
archetypal meme is a spirit it has its
own life it extends over centuries it's
capable of possessing people it's deep
it's biologically grounded the meme is
way deeper than
then darkens
realized and his followers and if you
push the meme idea
farther you get to the archetype well
then you're in trouble because then you
get to the religious and quickly
and so you know one of the things maybe
that Dawkins didn't realize is that some
memes are true
right and a true meme is religious and I
mean by definition
so or at least that's one way of looking
at it and so and and talking just mean
that a meme is an archetype a deep meme
is an archetype they're the same thing
it's the same idea
now
the problem that Dawkins would run into
is that well and Harris too is well are
there valid archetypes and I would say
well you guys you're hoist on your own
petard at that point because
valid memes are biologically
instantiated and you're biologists
and so like the biologist who I read
who were the deepest on the
philosophical front were biologists of
emotion and motivation because they saw
in the intrinsic structure of motivation
and emotion which is biologically
grounded the emerging point for
narrative and they're right and Harris
and Dawkins are rationalists and so the
domain of emotion and motivation in some
sense for them is contaminated I would
say with the religious which they
identify with the totalitarian impulse
and and over identify with the
totalitarian impulse but there's some
real sorting out that has to be done
there because
Dawkins also knows that behavior is
deeply biologically patterned it's like
what the representation of a deep
biological pattern in narrative is a
meme
but it's true me and a true meme is
religious
and so
what do you do with that well that
partly I've tried to talk to Harris with
some real success I would say and to
Dawkins with some success although not
as much as I would have liked and that's
partly my fault
um
but I also think I also think
I also think that both Dawkins and
Harris know that something's up
and I think with Dawkins that's probably
because
the humanists who are his children so to
speak haven't exactly turned out the way
that he had hoped and with Harris I
think it's more
the dawning realization of the necessity
of the Transcendent now like I said he
shies away from any concretization of
that that's why he's a Buddhist so to
speak you know because then you have God
and always ineffability you can't
criticize them if you can't
conceptualize them but the problem with
that is he can't bring him down to earth
either
and Jonathan paggio has made some
trenchant criticisms of Harris's
thinking in that regard it's like well
how do you bridge the gap between the
Transcendent and the particularized
without without a without a theology
because the theology is the bridge
Harris basically thinks well you can
have the ineffable
and you can have the the rabble with no
intermediary structures
it's a Protestant idea also in some
sense
although the Protestants had the book
right where it's for Harris it's more
like unmediated contact with the divines
like first of all
do you really think you're ready for
that do you because if the Divine is
the chimeras wielding flaming swords
that turn Every Which Way then you
better look out if you have any
unmediated contact because you might
find out that like so much of you has to
go that you can't even live
highly probable
it's notable how how much more
respectful you are of them than the
post-modernists in that sense and
there's actually a sort of sense of
admiration in the the way you speak
about yeah scientists man they're you
know Harris is a scientist and Dawkins
might be a great scientist
um
the post-modernists the fact that they
left so conveniently into the hands of
their a Priory Marxism
that that tempers my admiration greatly
I mean I've learned a lot from Foucault
and some from dareda uh almost nothing
from lakaya I can't read laca and I
don't think that's me but it maybe it is
but I don't think so
um but there's lots there's lots of meat
to chew on in Foucault but you know and
you can this is the thing about the
intellect you know it can reach
stratospheric Heights and go very
terribly wrong and it can do that
simultaneously and I mean you see that
in Egypt to some degree because
I'm a great admirer of Nietzsche he I
don't know if I've ever read anyone
who has as glitteringly brilliant as
Nietzsche it's really miraculous now
Dostoevsky on the narrative front is a
strong Contender and maybe surpasses him
in the final analysis but I don't know
if I've ever read anyone
who had the Stellar capacity of
Nietzsche
um
but he made a mistake and the mistake
was that he believed that human beings
could create their own values and
there are even which is what hires are
doing a little bit in some sense yes yes
although Harris to his credit he's
trying to ground those the reason he
insists that
value can be grounded in the scientific
is because he wants he wants a
Transcendent and objective source for
Morality and he's demanding that and the
demand is that it be found found in the
scientific realm and I even have some
what would you call I have some
admiration for that Viewpoint because I
do see that
there is a naturalistic ethos that
emerges so it emerges for example in the
sense of fair play that Even Rats
possess and that chimpanzees clearly
possess that that sense of balanced
reciprocity as the basis for social
organization and so that is a
naturalistic ethos and it is embedded in
the logos of the world and so even on
that front
even
heiress has something to say but there's
a big part of the story that is missing
there and and I think I think
that argument's actually over I think
Harris and Dawkins and the new atheists
lost now that isn't to say that what
they did is without value because it was
trenchant criticism
and you could say the same thing about
the postmodernists except that you know
they made this Unholy alliance with the
marxists
and
great well Dr Peterson thank you so much
for your time uh my pleasure uh
infinitely interesting and I'm sure
people listening will will have
thoroughly enjoyed that and I I wish you
a wonderful continued trip here in in
Britain and um uh yeah just thank you so
much hey my pleasure it was really good
to talk to you and uh thank you also for
your efforts on my behalf I have some
sense of what that cost you and so but
who knows what the rewards will be you
know not for agitating on my behalf but
for you know sticking to your own I've
got my soul and that's the most
important thing yeah yeah well fair
enough and it is and everyone needs to
know that because
it is the most important thing it's the
only thing in some real sense
perhaps
[Music]
um